you'll hear the terms balanced forces
and unbalanced forces a lot when you're
dealing with physics and what i want to
do in this video is give you a bunch of
scenarios and have you think about
whether the forces in these scenarios
are balanced or unbalanced so let's
start with a scenario where we have the
ground and then sitting on the ground we
have
we have a rock
now the force of gravity is going to be
pulling the rock downwards towards the
center of the earth and it's going to be
pulling it as essentially the weight of
the rock it's going to be pulling it
downwards let's say at with a force of
five newtons five newtons downwards but
then the rock is also being supported by
the ground the ground is keeping it from
being plummeted downward so the rot so
the ground is providing an upwards force
or normal force in this situation
the ground is providing a normal force
i'll do it in the green
in this situation of five newtons so
these forces have the same magnitudes
but they're going in opposite directions
so that is the first scenario now let's
think about another scenario so i'll
draw the rock again so i'll draw that
same rock
so now i will i will draw that same rock
we'll assume it's the same rock the
force of gravity is still downwards five
newtons
five newtons downwards and there's still
a normal force the ground supporting the
rock of five newtons upwards
5 newtons upwards
5 newtons upwards and now there's some
character who's trying to push the rock
so we have some character here
and he is trying to push the rock and
he's applying a force of
he's applying a force of two newtons to
the right but then there is a force of
friction between the rock and the ground
that is going to
and i'll do friction in orange two
newtons to the left
two newtons to the left so that right
over there is the force
the force of friction
is going against that guy's pushing now
let's do another scenario once again a
very similar scenario so let's draw
another scenario
where i have a rock now
i have maybe the same rock and here
i have a five newton force downwards
force of gravity like the rest of the
scenarios and i have the normal force
the ground is being support the rock is
being supported by the ground five
newtons upwards
and this guy now here has been able to
push a little bit harder he's pushing
he's pushing a little bit harder he
really put his back into it
and now he's pushing with a force of 3
newtons to the right and
and the force of friction is still
is still 2 newtons to the left so that
right over there is the force of
friction now let's do a couple more
scenarios now let's just imagine that
this is the ground
that's the ground and then i have the
rock
the rock is not resting on the ground
and so the only force i have acting on
the on the rock right now is the force
of gravity acting downwards we're
assuming we're not going to think too
much about actually let's think about it
a little bit let's also put so let's put
it
so i have the force of gravity that's 5
newtons down but i have some air
resistance here you could view it as the
force of friction of the air and that is
and let's say that that is one newton up
one newton up this is a force of
friction or you could call it air
resistance air resistance
all as this thing bumps into all of the
air particles as it is falling to the
ground and then the last scenario i'll
draw i'll draw the rock again since that
seems to be the theme for this video
the last scenario that's the ground the
rock is resting on the ground
the rock is green the rock is brown
the rock is
resting on the ground
and i have the force of gravity 5
newtons downwards
so 5 newtons towards the center of the
earth the rock is being supported
by the ground
5 newtons upwards
5 newtons upwards and now this guy is
pushing really hard so this guy right
over here is pushing
really hard
and so he's applying
he's applying let's make that 4 newtons
4 newtons
in that direction
you have two newtons from the force of
friction i won't draw that just yet and
you also have you also have another
character right over here who's trying
to keep this guy from pushing the block
so he's pushing he's pushing in the
other direction at one newton so you
have two newtons of the force of
friction you have this guy pushing one
newton against this guy's motion to the
left so between this guy and the force
of friction you have three newtons you
have three newtons going you have three
newtons going in that direction so now
i'll let you think about which of these
have an unbalanced force in them or
which of them another way to think about
which of these have a net force going
on
so let's look at the first scenario we
have a five newton's force of gravity
acting towards the center of the earth
five newton normal force of the ground
supporting the block these have the same
magnitude in the exact opposite
direction so they cancel out these
forces completely balance each other out
there is zero net force going on there
are no forces the way i've drawn it
going on in the horizontal direction so
you have zero net force these right here
are balanced or i guess we would not
consider this one of the scenarios where
we see an unbalanced force let's go over
here once again this five newtons and
that five newtons there they are
balancing each other and then in the
horizontal direction this guy's pushing
of two newtons in to the right is being
completely balanced by the force of
friction of two newtons to the left and
because they're balanced you're going to
have no net force and actually this
block isn't going to accelerate so once
again these are all balanced forces or
there's no unbalanced or or net force
going on right over here in this
scenario once again in the vertical
direction these forces are balanced the
normal force in this scenario is
balancing the force of gravity keeping
the rock from plummeting from
accelerating towards the center of the
earth
and you do have two forces that are
counteracting in the horizontal
direction this guy is pushing harder
with three newtons but the force of
friction now is only two newtons to the
left so you do have a net force to the
right three newtons to the right two
newtons to the left you have a net force
you have a net force of one newton
of one newton
one newton to one newton to the right or
you see it's right based on how i drew
the vector so you do have a net force
net force or another way of thinking
about it that this is a scenario where
you have unbalanced forces in particular
in the in the right left direction
now let's look at this over here
we only have forces the way i've
described it acting in this vertical
direction you have the force of gravity
five newtons downwards you have a
counteracting force the force of air
resistance one newton upward but they
don't completely balance out you still
have a net force you still have a net
force of 4 newtons downwards and so the
this is an unbalanced situation
then finally right over here we're
sitting on the ground in the vertical
direction normal force counteracting the
force of gravity those are balanced but
then in the horizontal direction this
guy to the right we have more force four
newtons than what we have going to the
left the three newtons was this guy plus
the force of friction so in this
situation you do have a net force in the
rightward direction once again a one
newton one newton force to the right a
one newton net force this is an
unbalanced that this is a scenario where
we have unbalanced forces